We have interesting new polls from the last
two days.
They are both terrible for Donald Trump.
But I actually want to do a little bit more
of a deep dove and look at the internals of
one of these polls.
So big picture, two new polls Tuesday poll
from Harvard.
Harris says Biden is up 12.
A poll from The New York Times today says
Joe Biden is up 14, which is absolutely stunning.
But let's focus in on some of the details
of today's New York Times poll.
In this poll, Joe Biden is up fifty to 36.
That's a 14 point lead.
You also have 14 percent of respondents under
the other category.
That includes people planning to vote, third
party people that are as yet undecided.
So you still have a lot in that other category.
Now, there are two particular areas that are
really hurting Donald Trump.
Number one is his response to Corona virus.
And number two is Trump's handling of race
relations.
Sixty percent of the country believes Trump
has mishandled Corona virus.
That's important because it is dramatically
higher than Trump's approval.
And it shows us that there is a big net deficit
that Trump is experiencing thanks to his absolutely
disastrous handling of the virus.
That includes among white voters and men.
Typically, white voters and men favor Trump,
even among white voters and men.
There is significant dissatisfaction with
Trump's handling of Corona virus then on race
relations.
Sixty one percent of voters say they disapprove
of Trump's handling of race.
Only 33 percent approve.
These are two of the most one sided areas
where Trump is underwater.
Now, a couple of other interesting things
from this poll.
Democrats and Republicans right now, according
to The New York Times poll, equally support
their party's candidates.
It is independents that are sort of making
the difference for Joe Biden.
So take a look at this.
Eighty five percent of Democrats say they're
going to vote for Joe Biden.
Eighty five percent of Republicans say they're
going to vote for Donald Trump.
That's even.
There are actually more Republicans nationally
than Democrats.
So in a sense, that favors Donald Trump.
But independents are leaning towards Biden
by a twenty one point margin, which is huge.
And then also interesting, the Trump campaign
has been pushing the idea that Biden is too
old to be president.
Remember, Trump turns 74 about 10 days ago.
Joe Biden, 77.
As of right now, 60 percent of voters disagree
that Joe Biden is too old.
So we don't know what's going to happen between
now and November.
But the key numbers I'm looking at are, number
one, an incumbent president polling only 36
percent four months before the election is
not good, number two.
And let me say a little bit more about that
in head to head reelection campaign.
So when you've had a strong third party candidate,
the numbers are different when you really
have a head to head matchup for president.
The the worst performing incumbent president
was John Adams, who got 39 percent of the
vote in eighteen hundred.
Even the wildly unpopular Herbert Hoover still
got 40 percent of the vote against FDR in
1932.
I don't think Trump will be under 40 no matter
what.
But if Trump ends up with anywhere close to
where he's polling now, 40 to 44, even 45
percent of the vote, this could be a historic
defeat.
If.
We actually go out and vote.
That's no, that's one metric that's important.
Trump polling in the 30s, four months before
the election.
The other really important metric is that
Joe Biden is regularly polling over 50 percent,
50 percent or more in polls.
If you look at polling at this point in 2016,
Hillary Clinton was only occasionally polling
50 percent.
And when she was, it really didn't go any
higher than 51, 52.
Joe Biden is regularly polling 50 percent
or even more.
And the reason that matters is that the undecided
vote.
The unsure vote.
The third party vote, as you get closer to
Election Day, it often will consolidate or
move towards the incumbent.
In this case, the incumbent is Trump.
What matters about Biden regularly being at
50 percent or more is that Biden doesn't need
to get any more support to win if we don't
get complacent and go out and vote.
We could see the economy tick up a little
bit if Corona virus gets under control.
It's only a blowout in November.
If we go out and vote, and that's a real question
mark.
So now that we've looked at all the polls,
what you should do is go out there pretending
as if every single one of these polls says
Trump is winning by one.
Right.
The idea the mentality you should have is
I don't care what the polls are.
I need to act as if my vote alone could give
a state to Joe Biden.
Of course, it's not literally the case, but
that's the attitude that we should have.
And we'll continue following the polls.
We'll continue following Trump's internals
among independents on corona virus, on race
relations.
But in the end, at the end of the day, we
all need to say on November 3rd, what would
I be doing right now if my vote could be the
vote that swings this election from Trump
to Biden?
Oh, I'd go out and vote.
That's exactly what I'm going to do.
And of course, many of us will vote early.
Many of us will be voting absentee.
And that just means we have the opportunity
to lock our vote in even sooner.
We don't even have
to wait until November.